worth it Philadelphia cheesesteaks today
I'm worth it we're gonna be trying three
awesome Philadelphia cheesesteaks at
three drastically different price points
to find out which one is the most worth
it at its price as you can see we're
joined here today by Quinta being hello
I am here today because fun fact I'm
from Philadelphia winter who is that
that is William Penn founder of
Pennsylvania and initiator of brotherly
love
and Philadelphia oh that's right the
city of brotherly love
let's do it gee thanks ed how you doing
tonight my name is Joe Clemente I'm
general manager John's roast pork where
itself Adelphia Snider Avenue I'll be
making you both a traditional pork
Italian and our self a cheesesteak
John's family's been here since 1930
it just started as like a local truck
stop it's a family style operation I've
never had a cheesesteak from here so I'm
really excited I'm from West Philly so
I've only gotten mine some corner stores
and West Philly they're all very good
it's just at a time sometimes a midnight
you're heading out you get done anyone
agree to meet I taste by the same spots
and I get the same things your state
doesn't go on and grow until you water
you tell me what your sandwich is how
you like it Marik and milder sharp
Rumble I make it like that takes a few
extra minutes but people seem like they
like it better that way okay oh my god
it's really steaming there whoa
beautiful whoa
there's what we came for this is one of
those foods that's a little bit more
like carnal if you know what I mean you
know messy is kind of like the ice cream
sundae had meats there's like a fudge
sauce with the cheese different little
things you could dress it up with it's a
bit I don't like banana shame yeah
cheese think is the mistake you make on
purpose like we know we're gonna feel
bad after this right now isn't it
bringing so much joy is this
representative of tea second filling
yeah 100% the cheese is perfect the
state just cut very nicely the bread is
good too it's not even on Moroso world
which is what most Philly cheesesteaks
are made alive it just has to be like
good bread good steak made with love if
you will we're gonna have a bite of this
pork now just to see what it's all about
in south boy yeah we're Italian we grew
up in the way that we always had pork I
mother make him back and forth because
of the price and stuff like ideas
growing up it was obviously cheaper than
Fleming on its cell phone off you can go
in any quarter and get somebody cheese
steak but to get a roast pork there's
only a few spots we're very lucky to
have both products that seemed like
everybody likes pork roasted I want I
want I want thank you oh and you guys
weren't a load of this season right no
it's a little bit of a secret a little
bit man I love a good secret delicious
spiced pork slowly roasted and juicy
Stephen you have to eat two more cheese
things today
you already have the head so we got some
cannolis at this well-renowned bakery
called is gross look at this you know
one of my favorite things is that this
string it's classy and classic actually
recommended by your friend and mine KP
airman he's grown yeah yeah it's
Christmas I said this is why Kate likes
it that's how it looks like hey guys hey
Gert yes but Adam is gonna eat it for
you
hey Kate watch this oh I'm so sorry we
gotta go back Kate I love you bye bye
thanks for the recommendation so now
we're on our way to our second
cheesesteak stop this one is gonna be a
little bit out of the ordinary there is
no stake in this juice it may
technically be acceptable for a
vegetarian to eat see this is why we do
stuff like this I always have surprises
my name is Josh now I'm originally from
Delaware I live in Philadelphia for 16
years and today I'm gonna prepare a few
of the Philly mushroom cheese steak
chicken pop is a bar with high craft
cocktails and elevated barf there's a
motivation behind the menu it's
basically like fine dining cooking all
day eating junk food in a combination of
two of what I like and taking bits and
pieces and executing it with fine dining
techniques so your cheesesteak has no
state what is the decision behind that
we're not just cooking for carnivores
we're cooking for everybody how much is
the meat of a vegetarian it's 80% water
so you can throw the water out and then
put it back in more flavor
we start off slowly formalizing fennel
and shallot after that's like that nice
coloring it you draw the sugars out of
the onion add the marcher the mushrooms
I select our usual Easter cremini and
shiitake it's a triple combination and
some [ __ ]
we cook down making a little pom do with
legio little parmesan of roasted garlic
the residual heat from the mushrooms and
it melts it's like chewy like mushroom
mass heat it up with slices of cheese on
it throw it in the oven slide it on top
of the bag yeah but a little bit of
every single shallots we're at a barge
so even though we're in Philly
I got a Manhattan are good the Fillies
de Quinta I'm sorry
cuenta do know that we were gonna be
doing this today I mean she knew that
we're gonna have a bunch of cheese
steaks but you didn't know that we'd be
having a vegetarian you know can't take
the magic out of Disneyland it's just a
land but [ __ ] cares
Cheers
[Music]
when the whole sandwich
I'm not missing the take it off so you
guys like it a lot
I'm not gonna lie I love this okay it
seems like he's composed this amazing
mushroom combination to mimic perfectly
what you get when you bite into a actual
Philly cheesesteaks
it is not impressed and that it is tasty
it's tasty it's very tasty it's messy
but it's white I feel great is life it's
good the breads good the truffles
amazing and mushrooms are done right
your mother cheese the cheese is great
so it's going to I feel like I'm slowly
getting you to admit that this is a
great cheese day so much listen I would
recommend this to any person who is
looking for a great vegetarian meal very
different that's what I'm saying this is
not a cheese steak this is like you had
a fantastic cheese steak sandwich but
then you just omitted this steak and
double the mushroom yeah sure I agree
that nothing can quite replace to taste
this day thank you I mean look at a cow
and look at a mushroom I've seen them
both and I want to eat the cow
[Laughter]
gin and pop All Things Considered pretty
good sandwich yeah yeah it was great
yeah I do a little bit deterring
changeups every once in a while
notoriously village you say back in 2015
the inaugural Philadelphia cheesesteak
Festival kicked off with a 450 foot long
Philly cheesesteak wow that's a lot of
cheese sake I always ask why why because
we can approve anything is for the love
of the game
yeah humans have always done that
they're like I love a thing I'm gonna
make the biggest version Egyptians love
triangles
how we got Texas Texas yeah they love
steak so much they were like we wouldn't
make a big version of it Texas we're on
our way to a new place a last place
called Berkeley Bryan Berkeley prime
steak house yes pretty fetid they're
gonna do a twist on a Philly cheesesteak
by adding lots of stuff on it that are
gonna cost a lot of money so twist is
it's gonna cost a little buddy you gotta
twist let's do it
[Music]
my name is Mark torski I'm the executive
chef and today I'm gonna show you how to
make 120 dollar cheesesteak is it the
Cadillac of cheese suits
I'd say better than the Cadillac you
might be the Tesla or Berkeley Prime
we've been around for 12 years we are a
boutique luxury steakhouse think of a
classic Steakhouse with a little bit of
modern flair to it at this point there's
so many different cheesesteak places to
go but they're basically the same thing
so we've taken the concept and elevated
it we want to offer the best quality of
every product we can find this seems
like it's gonna be like the Disneyland
of cheesesteaks it is a little epic
kotti because we're drawing our products
from japan from upstate New York from
different places so it is kind of like a
virtual Epcot Center of a cheesesteak
the three ingredients that really call
for the price are we're getting Japanese
be flown in weekly they do a Wagyu beef
it's a different breed of cow that is
known for the amount of fat that its
body can hold and so the fat translates
into flavor we get our bread across the
street at park restaurant our sister
restaurant the bread they make is some
of the best you can find info
we add a little bit of truffle butter
somebody will start toasting the bread
right at the same time as my saute cook
is starting to cook all the steak a
little bit of the truffle peelings and
some caramelized onions just kind of let
all that cook together we like a little
bit of carmelization on the steak but we
also like to have a little bit of that
that pinkness like you'd see almost on
like a medium steak just so that it's
even more tender and juicy the guy
toasting the bread is then making the
cheese sauce he's got to heat up a
bechamel sauce whisking some of that
shredded Italian truffle cheese make a
nice elasticity next week we layer a
little bit of some truffled foie gras
mousse foie gras is liver from a duck
and then just kind of envelope it with
this cheese sauce slice it bring it out
to the dining room where hopefully one
or more people are going to love it how
many Philly cheesesteaks you have to eat
together before you can be called you
know part of the family part of the
Philly fan family it doesn't work that
way okay yeah we get to select our
knives which is this delightful choose
your weapon at Berkeley press knives
from around the world I'll let you guys
go first I know Andrew wants this one I
can tell how did you know that nail it
yeah yeah it's it's just very Andrew
it's the most like simple but elegant
one is the one one Jesus yeah
all right what kind of champagne in this
class I'm ready are you guys ready -
let's do it I'm so pumped Thank You
Quinta thank you for having me guys yeah
what a wonderful day it's been a wild
adventure
[Music]
oh my god there's peas Wow cheese kicks
it off yeah Wow nice cheese she's really
like coats your tongue like all around
it's right now it's just like seeping
into my tastebuds
oh you're just tearing through that that
good huh so good
I am surprised how light it is all right
there's only slightly heavier and like a
ham and cheese croissant the truffle is
like it's a jacked-up mushroom mm-hmm so
it's not just adding an expensive
ingredient to a cheese steak sandwich it
actually makes sense within the context
of a cheese steak sandwich
that is so true I get cheese takes a
long time and I have to dress them up
with a bunch of things but this actually
like I don't need any ketchup mustard
anything the truffle really makes up for
the flavors that I usually create myself
I kind of wanna eat those peppers are
they hot almost spice is nice
Wow then beverages scorcher so much
juicier than I ever thought it was Billy
really put their name on the cheesesteak
by just like they weren't in there and I
get it now you know like they're just
different have you had a cheesesteak
somewhere else whoo and they call it a
Philly cheesesteak yeah yeah I have you
know you know that that was trash
there's one place in Los Angeles that
actually compares and it's called booze
but the people are from Philly they have
the rolls flown out and they sell tasty
cakes it's a tasty cake what's a tasty
cake this is just a tasty cake I mean
yes but no it's so much boy it's not I'm
sorry it's okay oh my god kind of
cultured slide all right let's get some
tasty cakes okay so we did it we ate the
cheese sticks first of all thank you so
much for being an amazing guest on a
little bit thank you guys for having me
we trusted the process of worth it which
Billy cheese think was the most worthy
at this price we're starting with Andrew
today nice I think my worth it winner
has to go to Berkeley Brian
oh but only if you eat it by yourself no
sharing $120 a very fancy steak house
like Barclay prime I can think of no
better way to show up everybody in a
restaurant than to just slobber down a
full cheese steak by myself while they
eat like asparagus and whatever that is
what they look like my were that winner
goes to gin and pop I'd down that
sandwich he found it in less than three
minutes it was God it was good it was
just a really tasty sandwich day which
my birthday choice is
take from gin and pop the fact that I
can get cocktails here and I don't know
if he knows this about me but I'm a
fancy girl I like a good cocktail the
experience overall was the most worth of
for me there has not been a greater
plunge with since why cuz six cents I
don't know it Adam whose you're worth it
winner Adam says booze Philly
cheesesteak in Los Angeles California
whose is pretty freakin good I'm gonna
lie to you booze is a cheese steak of
the hood but it's in LA it's crazy
hey check out our Instagram it's new
it's at BuzzFeed worth it you guys there
oh yes
[Music]